It's time to look at
updating our forecast view.
A quick glance at the key lines
gives me a sense of deja vu.
We've certainly seen
these metrics before.
Furthermore, the entire Today view is
nearly identical in layout to the top
half of the detail view, except that it
doesn't have the space views at center,
our detail view.
The extra vertical space in the app bar
is the same height as our list items.
Because we're somewhat space
constrained, we're using a minimal 8 dp
of spacing for the area between high and
low temperatures in the daily forecast.
And of course, we see that
the Today view casts a shadow.
The shadow helps create the illusion
that the screen is made up of
a physical material.
But how do we cast this shadow?
To make this easier for developers,
Android L adds a new parameter into
our layout language, elevation.
Paraphrasing from our Material guide,
elevation is the aspect of
the Material Design language that helps
users understand the relative importance
of each element and focus their
attention to the task at hand.
It combines the familiar and physical
materials with magical properties
that designers can leverage
to create delightful moments.
The elevation of a view,
represented by the z property,
determines the visual
appearance of its shadow.
Views with higher z values cast larger,
softer shadows.
Views with higher z values also
occlude views with lower z values.
However, the z value of view
does not affect the view's size.
Elevation is used for
the static state of a view.
Translation z is used to create
animation such as this one,
where widgets temporarily rise above the
new plane when performing some action.
Note that this video
represents Material's ideals
rather than the reality of
the Android implementation.
Elevation animations are typically used
to help signify action in response to
user touch.
Setting the elevation parameter
on a view group will cause
it to cast a shadow on other views.
You have to be a bit careful as it
also changes the way views clip.
Higher elevation views
will occlude other views,
even if they appear first in the layout.
The appbar_elevation
dimension is four dp.
We can add this to our dimensions or
just include the Android design library,
which defines this dimension.
To make the changes to our
portrait forecast view,
we need to make changes in three places.
First, we'll update
the toolbar section to create
the app bar from the design
in activity_main.xml.
We'll make changes to the Today view
in the list_item_forecast_today layout.
And we'll modify the rest of
the forecast list items in
the list_item_forecast layout.
Before you start coding, you'll grab
another code update, which includes
correctly sized images, updated list
selectors, and some useful dimensions.
Because we have network
loadable image sets,
you want to constrain the width of
our icon images in the forecast list
to 40 dps in the list icon
dimension we give to you.
You can use the touch_selector_white
to replace the Today touch selector.
The large numbers are 32 dp,
while the text view is 49 dp wide.
I'm intentionally using dp instead of sp
here because I don't want these numbers
to change size when the system
font is set to large size.
I'm intentionally using dp instead of sp
here because I don't want these numbers
to change size when the system
font is set to large size.
We're pretty tight on space
on narrow devices already.
The app bar is pretty simple.
We take advantage of the fact that the
Toolbar will center its children with
respect to the entire layout if we use
layout gravity equals center horizontal.
Therefore, we include the Imageview
inside of the toolbar with a height of
listPreferredItemHeight and
a marginTop of actionBarSize,
while having wrap_content for
width to let the Toolbar center it.